assume that the united states economy is
currently in a short run equilibrium
with the actual unemployment rate above
the natural rate of unemployment part a
says draw a single correctly labeled
graph with both the long run phillips
curve and the short run phillips curve
label the current short run equilibrium
point p
so like always pause this video get a
pencil and paper out and see if you can
sketch this yourself before we work
through this together you'll get more
out of this video
all right now let's do this together so
if we're thinking about phillips curves
we're going to we're going to have two
axes our horizontal axis
is going to be the unemployment rate
unemployment
rate which is going to be expressed as a
percentage
and our vertical axis is going to be our
inflation rate which is going to be
expressed
inflation rate which is also going to be
expressed as a percentage
so let's start with the long run
phillips curve so the long run phillips
curve that's just going to be
fixed at the natural rate of
unemployment so that's just going to be
a vertical line
so
let's just put that right over there and
let me label it that is our long run
phillips curve and now let's do the
short run phillips curve well the short
run phillips curve shows this
association between our inflation rate
and our unemployment rate high rates of
inflation are associated with low
unemployment
and low rates of inflation are
associated with high rates of
unemployment and so our short run
phillips curve is going to look
something
like that and so let me just label that
short run phillips curve and now they
want us to label the current short run
equilibrium point p so a lot of times
when people talk about equilibrium
points it's tempting to just look at the
intersection of these two curves but
that wouldn't be the case here the
equilibrium point is going to be some
point along our short run phillips curve
in fact every point on our short run
phillips curve represents a potential
equilibrium point if we were looking at
aggregate demand versus aggregate supply
well then our equilibrium point would be
at the intersection of the aggregate
demand and short run aggregate supply
but here our equilibrium point could be
any point along our short run phillips
curve and they say that we're currently
in a place where the actual unemployment
rate is above the natural rate of
unemployment so the natural rate of
unemployment is here the actual rate of
unemployment is higher but we're going
to be on our short run phillips curve so
we could be at a point just like that so
let's just label that point p
so part b says assuming no policy
actions are taken will the short run
phillips curve shift to the right or
upward shift to the left and downward or
remain the same in the long run explain
so pause this video again and see if you
can work through that before i do that
with you
so the way to think about this is
when
aggregate output
aggregate
output
is less than less
than
full
employment
output
you have higher unemployment a higher
unemployment rate and lower inflation
you
have
a higher
unemployment rate above the natural rate
higher unemployment rate
and
lower
inflation
this decreases inflation expectations
this decreases
inflation
expectation so one way to think about it
at a given unemployment rate you will
over time have a lower inflation rate
because of the lowered inflation
expectations and so instead of our
inflation rate being right over there it
might be right over here and so for this
point on our short run phillips curve
instead of the inflation rate being
there it might be over there and so it
would actually shift the short run
phillips curve to the left and downwards
now they're not asking us to draw that
so i don't want to do that here i just
did that to hopefully help explain the
intuition but i will just answer their
question right over here so this
so this
shifts
shifts the short run phillips curve
left
slash downward
downward
all right part c if the federal reserve
bank wants to lower unemployment
what expansionary open market operation
should it use so pause the video again
and see if you can answer that
well there are several tools that the
federal reserve bank can use to lower
unemployment it could change the reserve
requirements for banks
but here they're explicitly talking
about open market operations and so the
typical open market operation that the
federal reserve bank would do if it
wants to lower unemployment it wants to
inject more money into the economy it
wants to increase the amount of reserves
in banks which will of course increase
the money supply and so to do that
they will go out into the open market
and buy bonds
so the federal reserve bank will buy
will buy bonds remember when they're
buying bonds the people who sell those
bonds will take those federal reserve
notes deposit them in banks
that will increase the reserves of the
banks the banks will be able to lend
more and the money supply will increase
part d how will the open market
operation you identified in part c
affect each of the following
federal funds rate explain
so i just touched on it we can say
buying
bonds
will
increase
bank reserves
bank
reserves
which will lead the federal funds rate
to go down so the fed
funds
rate
will
decrease remember the federal funds rate
is the rate which banks borrow reserves
from each other if there's a total of
more reserves now well then there's less
demand to borrow and there's more supply
of reserves so the cost of borrowing
which is the interest rate the federal
funds rate will decrease
real interest rates in the short run
well this will also decrease
also
decrease
an increase in the money supply so i
could say n
increase
in
reserves
slash money supply
money supply
will
decrease
nominal
and
real
interest rates
interest
rates
in
the short run in the short run there is
a situation where maybe you have runaway
inflation the nominal rates go down but
somehow that doesn't affect the real
rate as much but in the short run we can
pretty confidently say that if nominal
interest rates are going down that real
interest rates will go down as well
and then there's a last part here that
is off the screen and it says given your
answer in part d2 this last part what is
the effect on real gross domestic
product gdp in the short run explain
well lower
real
interest rates
interest
rates
lead
to
more
interest
interest sensitive
consumption
and investment
investment and we're talking about
investment we could talk about plant
and equipment
equipment
which should increase gdp real gdp
which
should
increase
real gdp in the short run
in
the
short
run and we are done